To begin with our prayer, dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God,
to place my absolute nothingness in the heart of the most holy Trinity,
to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my existence,
by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner, may I live,
pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings,
wants or desires and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure and that I remain so docile to the movements of
your divine will, that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light,
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers. Amen.
So I want to begin this evening with April the 4th 1926 and we have some very wonderful messages
from the Lord given to us this evening. Jesus is going to tell us that the divine will forms the
complete resurrection of the soul in God. So all of you who are teaching others, please take very
clear note of this that this is a journey. I've been saying that for quite some time now and
that it involves literally the we are raised from the dead by the Lord and all that's the
the death of self, the death of the world, the death of all the past, the death of unbelief,
the death of on love, everything and we're raised to a completely new life in Christ. It's a very
wonderful message. So Louisa said finding myself in my usual state, I felt all immersed in my beloved
Jesus and my poor mind wandered through the divine knowledge. Now know what she's saying.
My mind wandered through the divine knowledge. She's not saying it wandered through beautiful
ideas about God or wonderful texts about this that and the other. No, she goes directly to the
center which is God himself. Everything was in silence on my part and on the part of Jesus. In
other words, the Lord let her do it. That's her privilege. Nor am I able to say what I understood.
That's one Corinthians two nine. We don't have the ability to express the supernatural afterwards.
However, Jesus assumed his teaching. The translation says speaking, which doesn't make sense in English.
He resumed his teaching and said to me, my daughter, everything I do in the soul, it surpasses all
that I did in creation. Now, it's a massive sentence. He says, every single thing I do in the soul,
not the whole thing, not just the raising you from the dead, but every single thing,
every movement, every grace, everything, he says surpasses what I did in creation. See,
each added knowledge of my perfections which I manifest and each truth which pertains to the
divinity. Both of them form a new heaven that I extend in the soul. Now, you know that
the Lord has said many times in history, behold, I make all things new. I want to give you some
references for that. Isaiah 43 18, Revelation 21 5 and two Corinthians 5 17. Behold, I make all
things new. That is what he's trying to do all the time is to recreate who we are because we
spoiled his original creation and he wants to bring us back to his original idea. So each thing
creates a new heaven inside of us. So he is in the act of creating all the time, all the time.
So when you become very aware of your weakness and struggle, which as you know is very strong
sometimes, you just say to the Lord, create in me a new heart, the Sam 51, the misery,
create in me a new heart. If you want me to live this life, create this life in me so that I can
actually respond to you. Just the very fact of reminding ourselves that he is a creator,
solves an enormous number of problems as far as I'm concerned. As the soul rises in these truths,
now notions were not supposed to just read them and say they're nice. We're supposed to let these
truths actually do their work inside of us. As the soul rises in the truths she has known in
order to resemble her creator, it is new suns that I come to form within the space of these heavens.
Now notice within the space and we've already dealt with the fact that he has to create
a greater and greater and greater capacity within us to be able to receive all that he wants to give
us. We don't have the capacity to begin with, but the more we respond to what he does, the more he
actually increases our capacity. So that he not only gives you the grace, he gives you the ability
to take it and he creates the space for you to be able to deal with this. So the new heavens are
arising in this new earth that we are bit by bit as we respond to the Lord. So each grace that I
pour and each time I renew her union with me, that's when we fuse with him. Each time
our seas that are laid in the soul. So the more often we fuse into the divine will, the better.
If you can do it a hundred times a day, that's absolutely fine. I have my own shortcut for that.
I say Lord, I want to fuse all of me in all of you all the time. That's just my shortcut.
And so each grace that I pour and each time I renew her union with me, these are seas that are
laid in the soul. And her love and her response from the sweet murmuring of these seas. Now,
one of the things that Louisa reminds us frequently about, and it fascinates me considering that she
was 47 years in bed, and that is the murmuring of the oceans. It's always something that has
completely fascinated me since I was a child, just listening to the murmuring of the ocean. I say,
Lord, the ocean is talking to you. And it is. And he said that our love for the Lord and our
response to his grace is creating this murmuring in the seas of grace that he's given to us.
And it also creates the mighty waves as the spirit of God moves mightily in us.
And these rise up to heaven and come to unload themselves at the foot of the divine throne. Now,
Louisa's been telling us in all the volumes up to now that we bring everything before the throne
of God. Okay, as the soul practices her virtues. Now, there's an emphasis here on the fact that we
don't give up being virtuous, we have to bring virtue to perfection through the divine will.
As the soul practices her virtues, since the body too contributes to the exercise of them,
that means we get a lot of challenge through the body and through its senses. And so we have
a field of action in which the divine will work its way in us and for us to cooperate.
The body can be called the little field of the soul. That's wonderful. It's the area
where the soul has to work. And in the early stages of this journey, we have to work an enormous
amount in the body to try and get what St Francis of the CC called brother ass to actually cooperate.
And so the body can be called the little field of the soul over which I lay the most
beautiful flowery meadows in which I delight in creating ever new plants, flowers and fruits
and notice creative. As soon as we give any response to him, it stimulates him to create. He is a
creator. So creating is his thing, if I can put it in a very non theological way. So then he goes on
and he wants to say that God is continuously creating in us. So he actually needs a continuous
response from us as well to give him the freedom to do that. Just as I am one single act which
after it is done once is done forever. He only has to say let there be light and light is there
forever. Let us make all this vegetation upon the earth and he makes it and it continues forever.
Let us make the animals in the fields and they continue forever. One act but it is continuous.
Creation also was only one single act but just as in creation my single act continues.
How does it continue? By preserving it ever new, by preserving it whole and fresh and that's the way
my creating in souls must be continuous as well. I never stop he says. So we've heard him say to
Louisa over and over and over again do not stop. You must continue. You must continue and therefore
I recommend that before you sleep at night that you lay your intentions before the Lord so that
he knows that while you're sleeping you're still busy cooperating with his holy will.
I am always always in the act of forming more beautiful things, surprising and new things
unless I find souls who close the door. Now he will work in us unless we say no. The moment he says
no he will go. The Lord is the exact opposite of the enemy. You give him the tiniest chink he comes
in and he dominates and makes life impossible for you. The Lord is the exact opposite. If you say no
to him he will go because he gave you free will and he will respect it. So be very very careful
what you say to God. Very careful. So he does all these beautiful things unless he finds souls that
are closed to him and these souls arrest my continuous act of creation. Now if we're closing the door
to him arrests his continuous act of creation that means then you deteriorate because we just read
that part of his creation is preserving his creation whole and entire and completely new and fresh.
So if we close the door to him in any area of our lives that is going to cause disintegration
and it'll be our own fault because we've now allowed the creator to continue to work in us.
But when that does happen he said I find another device I abound I multiply my continuous act
in the souls who keep the doors open. In other words he keeps the rest of us interceding for them
and substituting for them and making reparation for them so as they will open the door again.
So I abound and I multiply my continuous act in the souls who keep the door open and with them
I delight and continue the office of Creator. So I want to give you Sam 118 verses 19 to 24 for that.
"But you know where this continuous act of mine is never interrupted," he said. "It is in the soul
who lives in my will." So somebody asked me a few weeks ago what precisely do you mean by saying
lives in my will and I can only give you my own opinion. As far as I'm concerned living in the
divine will involves every thought, every word, every action, every desire, every motivation,
everything. That's what living in it is. I'm living in the air. I'm breathing that air day and night
even when I'm asleep I'm breathing. So I'm living in the atmosphere, okay. A fish lives in water,
it is there 24, 7, 3, 6, 5. The fish wouldn't know what land was. So living in the divine will
means being completely immersed in the divine will. It's permanent, it involves every single part of
me, okay. So when we give this commitment to the Lord the divine will then prepares our souls to be
the true brides of Christ and brides that are totally given to him. So to me that's what living
in the divine will is. And I would distinguish it from saying beautiful prayers in the divine will
because if you say a beautiful prayer as we've just said the rosary in the divine will and you
have fused yourself at the beginning of that rosary then you are fused for the length of time of that
prayer. But what about all the rest of it? Some people can make the mistake of thinking I'm living
in the divine will if I say these beautiful prayers and I might scandalize you by saying that I think
you can prove you're living in the divine will even without saying any of those prayers because
it's every thought, every word, every action, every motivation, every desire, every movement,
everything inside of me. Okay, it's terribly important for us to realize that. So this is 100%
commitment to the Lord and that's why in the early volumes I kept on giving you Deuteronomy
6, 4 to 10, hero Israel, the Lord your God is one Lord and you shall love the Lord with all
100% your heart, all your soul, all your mind, all your being. Now the Lord asked that at the time
of the Exodus so he's asking that of us at a much higher plane living in the divine will.
So the soul who lives in the divine will gives him complete freedom to act. Ah yes Jesus said
only in her can I do freely what I want. Notice the freely because the will has been handed over
in union with the divine will and therefore the divine will is free to act. If the human will is
still operating then the divine will find blocks within the soul. So only in one living in the
divine will can I act freely whenever I want. Notice that whatever I want and it's also
whenever he wants as well because my will which the soul contains prepares her for me to receive
my fiat that came out of creation. So the divine will works in us to enable us to open up and truly
truly truly surrender to the divine will. When you consider that this is a lifelong struggle for us
it is an absolute incredibly wonderful marvel that our blessed mother had this from the very first
instant of her being. Therefore we have to be always attentive let your flight be always in my will
let your fusing be always in my will always commit yourself always always always always.
So in the next paragraph then Jesus explains that it was his resurrection that put the seed
of resurrection in place for us that would enable us when we were ready to rise from the dead. Now
spiritual writers in the centuries before us would speak about conversion as a rising from the dead
and correctly and so in dealing with the divine will the Lord is speaking about that at its highest
plane. After this Louisa said I was thinking about the resurrection of our Lord and coming back
again he added my daughter my resurrection completed sealed and returned to me all honors
which were taken away of course in this passion and death. It called to life all my works which
of course were now permanent forever. All the works which I did in the course of my life on earth
and it formed the seed of the resurrection for souls so Jesus' resurrection forms the seed for
us to be able to rise again. I can only rise because he rose if he didn't rise in the dead I couldn't
it's not actually possible. I live because he lives if he didn't live I couldn't live I would
never have been brought into being. So these formed the seed of the resurrection of souls Jesus said
and even of the bodies in the universal judgment which you read about in Revelation 21 verses 11 to 13.
So without my resurrection my redemption would have been incomplete and my most beautiful works
would have been buried because everybody would have said he was a complete failure once he died
on the cross. It was the resurrection that put the QED on absolutely everything. So he said it's
the same for the soul if she doesn't rise again completely in my will that your total surrender
100% it can't be 99.9. If she does not rise again completely in my will all of her works will
remain on complete. It will never reach the level that God wants. So if coldness for divine things creeps
in watch this carefully now. If passions oppress her and vices tyrannize her these will form the tomb
in which to bury her. Now I'll give you that in very simple English it's an awful lot easier and
quicker to fall down a mountain than to climb it. So these will form the tomb in which to bury her
because since the life not as capital L the life of my will is missing the one who makes the divine
fire rise again will be missing. It's only the divine will truly living in us as life not just as
something totally outside of us but as life as the center of life in us if that is missing then the
divine fire that enables us to rise again will be missing. The one who with one blow kills all
passions and makes all virtues rise again will be missing that one is the divine will. My will is
more than the sun which eclipses everything fertilizes everything and converts everything into light
and forms the complete resurrection of the soul and God. So you can see therefore I'm saying this
particularly for those who are teaching others. You can see that it's not conversion to the divine
will that we're talking about. That's at level one way back before volume one of Louise's writings
it's back in the lower spirituality. That's where conversion is. What you have here in the divine
will is complete 100% resurrection to the level of spirit. A fantastic message and it needs to be
gone over very very slowly. So on April the 9th 1926 Jesus compares virtues and the divine will. So
this is where we were in the past and where we are to be. So Louise said I was thinking to myself
my sweet Jesus says so many great and admirable highest and wonderful things about the divine will
and yet it seems to me that creatures don't have that concept which is absolutely true.
How many people could you talk to about the divine will? You don't have that concept which the
divine will deserves nor that great impression of the wonders that are in it. In other words people
are ignorant of what the divine will truly is. On the contrary it seems that they place the divine
will on the same level of the virtues. Now please will you put a VIP on this or a yellow sticker or
something if you are a teacher because here's one of the answers that you need for people who
object to the divine will and unfortunately the people that I have dealt with who objected to
the divine will were priests and religious and they'll tell you we're already committed to the divine
will. As a community of sisters said to me once but we have those of obedience to the divine will
you don't I said I'm not speaking at that level and he even having spoken to them intensely for an
hour they didn't get it at all they just thought I was a bit strange and so Louise is talking about
something terribly important here that the vast majority of people put the divine will on the
level of the virtues. In other words I'm keeping the commandment what are you talking about I've
never robbed a bank I've never killed anybody what are you talking about you know so you put the
virtues on the same level and that's lethal and maybe they care about those more than they
care about the most holy will of God. In other words in the ordinary spirituality you have people
caring more about growing in humility and growing in patience and growing in this and growing in
that growing in the other and they're concentrating on that instead of concentrating on the divine
will itself in other words going to the heart of the matter. So Jesus moved in Louise's interior and
said my daughter do you want to know why and the answer is yes because their palates are not purged
now this is VIP PPPP but green wine gold marks on this one. Their palates are not purged in other
words they have not been purified of the past they only have a taste for what they knew in the past
they have no taste for this higher spirituality. That's like saying I'm a teacher in school
and I have a class of six-year-olds in front of me and I want to teach them trigonometry
well now I'm going to lose their attention on the first sentence they've no taste for that
but if I do ordinary adding and subtracting and multiplying with numbers they're able to handle
oh yeah they're interested and so the problem you have with people still on the level of the virtues
is that their palates are not purged and they are accustomed to the ordinary foods of the low world
which are the virtues and not to the celestial and divine food which is my will. So here you're
dealing with food on two completely different planes. This celestial food is appreciated only by those
who consider the earth material things and even people as nothing. You're probably going to have a
problem with that one or as fully ordered by God. Many people misunderstand relationships
in a family and they seem to think we put that before everything else. The answer is we put God
before everything else we put the divine will before everything else. As Peter and John said to the
Sanhedrin in Jerusalem in Acts chapter four or five he said we have to listen to God rather than men
you put God first and therefore the living on the level of the divine will is a spiritual plane
that the people around you will not understand and therefore they'll misunderstand you and
there will be problems because of that. Now to treat people as nothing that doesn't mean they've
no value that doesn't mean you don't love them but it's the nothing by compared with the infinite
it's the nothing compared to the all and then he adds the next little phrase which I think is very
interesting that you treat them as fully ordered in God. Now the problem is if you're talking to
someone who is fully disordered with drugs drink alcohol sex whatever the thing is that's
disordering them and treat them as fully ordered in God they wouldn't be able to cope at all.
But in a good family situation where relationships are fairly okay yes you can treat them at your own
level. The virtues which can be practiced on earth are rarely exempt from human purposes this is
terribly important. What that means is that if you are not completely given to God there's always
the element of what in it for me. What can I gain? You may have seen ads as I've seen them on
television in which person is being asked you know why are you doing this wonderful thing like you're
going to some country and helping people in dire need and you often get an extremely inadequate
response I enjoy it it makes me feel good. Now that's the level of the virtues and it's very much
lower than living in the divine will. There's something in it for me okay. So Jesus says that
the virtues the level of the virtues which can be practiced are rarely exempt from human purposes
from self-esteem in other words I enjoy it I get something out of it. From self-lory well I'm
better than the rest of them I mean they didn't go to Africa and go to some war-torn country.
Love of appearing I think it's very interesting in other words you want to be seen
you want to be interviewed you want to be noticed or the need to please people now the need to please
people is very very common in other words that life will be easier if I just give in and please
them but giving in and pleasing people can bring you down your mountain from the divine will to a
very low level rather quickly and it will make you compromise in areas that you shouldn't compromise
and so in giving you the detail here the the Lord is telling us just how serious our commitment
to him really is. All these aims that he has just said the self-esteem the self-glory love
of appearing and pleasing people are like many tastes for the ordinary palette notice ordinary
the ordinary palette of the soul in other words you can handle this you're used to it and many
times one operates more for the tastes than for the good that the virtue contains that is the answer
I gave you it makes me feel good I feel better for doing it in other words I am doing it to gain
something from myself they may not realize it but it's actually the words come out when they're asked
it's really sad in a way so this is why the virtues fail more easily the word in my page says
breach I think we would use the word fail for there and this is why the virtues can fail more
easily because the human will always gain something now when the human will gain something it cannot
be completely given to God not at all and that's why the Lord tells us over and over and over again
that the human will has to be sacrificed on the other hand the first thing that my will knocks down
is the human will and it tolerates no purpose which gives of the human so you're seeing the exact
opposite of what we've just been reading now so this is a plane which is so much higher
so if I can give a very unworthy example here it would be the difference in sailing to another
country in a small boat and flying in a 747 they're just two entirely different experiences
and so the Lord will not tolerate in us something where the human will can gain because the more
the human will gains the less the divine will can reign my will is from heaven and it wants to place
in the soul now inside of the soul so the room has to be made for it that which is divine
and which belongs to heaven therefore everything that specs of the low earth has got to go
therefore one's own self remains on an empty stomach and feels itself dying the ego has to go
it has to go not my will but dying be done I've said to you has got to be our motto I've said it
from volume one okay not my will but dying be done so the ego has to go so in feeling her own
ego dying and in losing the hope of having any other food left the soul makes up her mind to take
the food of my will and sometimes in order to help us to really make that decision the Lord has to
allow us to be disillusioned about something or other that we were expecting to get some benefit
from and so it's in our poverty that we turn to him and as she takes this divine food of the divine
will her palate is purged in other words you are slowly trained to appreciate spiritual things
as distinct from the earthly things and in case you think I'm putting the banner too high
just do a tiny reflection after the class and say to yourself the people around you they may in fact
be in the same house and they may just be people around you as in your neighbors or anything what
they would do for recreation would it be what you would do now have you changed
her palate is purged and she feels the taste of the food of my will which is such that she would
not exchange it at the cost of her life so in the next paragraph then the Lord says no compromise
what I want is total transformation and it has to be 100 percent not 99.9 human beings like keeping
something back my will does not know how to compromise he said the virtues do and the virtues do
with the low and the little things that are done on the earth rather the divine will wants to keep
everything and everyone as a footstool at its feet that is sacrificed and the divine will wants to
change the whole interior of the soul in case you don't know where you're going would you ever take
that little phrase off the page and write it on a separate sheet of paper and realize that's what
he's after he wants to change the whole interior of the soul because we have come from a very worldly
situation we've come from very worldly influences and so the Lord has to create new heavens and a new
earth inside of us I want to change the whole interior of the soul and the very virtues I want
to change them all into divine will so that when you love your loving divinely when you forgive
your forgiving divinely you're not just forgiving grudgingly at a lower level in a word the divine
will wants its own heaven in the depths of the soul now you can call this a new Bethlehem a new
Bethany a new Nazareth whatever you want but he wants his own heaven in the depths of the soul
otherwise it would remain hindered and would not be able to carry out its divine life so here is the
great difference that exists between the virtues and my will between the sanctity of the virtues
and the sanctity of the divine will and this is where we have to explain to people that
the sanctity of the divine the divine will is the highest level of sanctity possible for us
and the amazing thing is that it's being offered to us at a time of terrible crisis in the church
and the world so here's the great difference that exists between the virtues and my will between
the sanctity of one and the other the virtues can be of creatures and conform a human sanctity
at the most but my will is of God and it can form a sanctity which is truly and fully
divine and that is our vocation what a difference however since the creatures are used to looking
down below they're more impressed by the little lamps of the virtues than the great sun of my will
now i want to illustrate that by a story that happened when i was a child
it was just after the well i was born during the second world war so life was very difficult for
us all and money was extremely scarce and at one stage we had visitors to our home and one of my
aunt offered my youngest sister a white penny in those days we called it a half crown
and the child had never seen one of these silver things before and two big tears came down her face
and she said but don't you have a brown penny 25 times less value and afterwards we showed her
what she had chosen as distinct from what was offered to her and many many years later i said
to the lord why does that story stay with me and why does it still hurt and he said i allowed you to
feel what i feel when people ask me for trifles and i can give them everything
they asked me for little human trifles and i can give them the divine will and divine
fantasy and i can give them absolutely everything and all happiness and all be attitude even on this
earth i can give them everything and they asked me for trifles and so that's the reason why i'm
giving you that little story because for me it actually illustrates his pain okay so now he's
going to give an illustration and of course his favorite image is always the sun so louisa said
afterwards i found myself outside of myself in the act in which the sun was rising all things
changed their appearance the plants became brilliant the flowers received the life of their fragrance
and of the different colors which the light of the sun brought to them all things received
sip by sip the life of the light of the sun in order to develop and be formed and yet the light
and the heat were just one thing it is a very awkward sentence there which i've made into ordinary
english and you couldn't see anything else there's just light and heat but where did so many effects
come from and where did all these different colors which it gave to nature where did they come from
and so my sweet Jesus said my daughter why does the sun contain the seed of the quantity the seed
of the substance of all colors it's because the sun that light is greater than the goods that it
contains and therefore it keeps them all it eclipses within itself you look up and you only see light
and he has said this many many times in the volumes you cannot give something you don't possess
in the same way the sun would not be able to give either fecundity or sweetness or fruits or color
to flowers nor could it work so many wonders on the earth as to transform it from the abyss of
darkness into the abyss of light if it didn't have all of that stuff within itself so the sun
is the symbol of my will he said as the divine will rises over the soul now remember the sun rising
and changing everything brings her to life and vibifies her it be jewels her with graces it gives
you the most beautiful shades and divine colors it transforms her in God to Corinthians 3 18
and it does this all at once it's enough to let it rise for it to operate wonderful things
and that's why the most important thing is for us to fuse in the divine will and stay there
and stay there all of me in all of you all the time okay stay there because once the divine will
is free to operate in the soul he will do his divine things it transforms her in God not into
God but in God is a divine transformation and the divine will does this all at once by giving
my will loses nothing just as the sun loses nothing by doing so much good to the earth
on the contrary it remains glorified in the work of the creature our being is always in perfect
balance and when we reach the pinnacle will be in perfect balance as well all ordered body soul
and spirit it neither increases nor will it decrease but you know how this happens well imagine the sea
full to the brim a wind invests its surface and forms its waves which overflows outside in other
ways you get a tsunami in swelling the sea has lost nothing and just as the water has overflowed
outside so have they immediately risen they appear at the same level as before the sea never appears
to ever lose no matter what it does and the sun appears not to lose anything no matter what it
gives either so the same happens between the soul and God is the very important thing that Jesus is
aiming at she can be called the little wind now this is the soul which forms the waves of the divine
sea in such a way and we would do that by our prayers in our rounds in such a way that she can
take as much war for us she wants now you know i could give you an endless number of references
there including Isaiah 55 one common drink of the waters the water in the scriptures represents
salvation and she can take as much as she wants but our sea will remain always at its level no
matter what we take we are so tiny by comparison with the infinite that it is infinite esmal what
we could take even if we took everything that we needed our sea always remains at its level
because our nature is not subject to undergoing change is the word we're sort of into mutations
now with this pandemic therefore the more you take the more delight you give to me and the more
glorified i will be in you in other words you saying open yourself up let God be God and allow
yourself to live at this divine level so in the next paragraph then a such an excellent teacher
he goes over it and over and over it again so he says your choice is to choose the human or choose
the divine and take the consequences but the choice is yours you've got free will so afterwards
louisa was thinking about the difference between one who let yourself be dominated by the will
of god and one who let yourself be dominated by the human will at that moment i saw a person
before my mind bent over her forehead touching her knees covered with a black veil and wrapped
within a tick fog which prevented her from seeing the light now there's a very very good image of
someone living in the human will dominated by the human will poor one she seemed to be drunk and
staggering she fell to the right and then to the left truly she aroused pity now as i was seeing
this my sweet jesus moved in my interior telling me my daughter this is the image of one who
let yourself be dominated by her own will they really need to go back and read and if you control
to draw that image and it'll stop you from living in the human will the human will
bends the soul so much that she is forced always to look to the low earth i want to give you one
corinthians two fourteen the unspiritual don't get it they just don't she's forced to always look
at the low earth and by looking at the earth this is what she knows and what she appreciates
this knowledge and this love form so many exhalations they form that tick and black
fog which enraps her completely and removes her from the sight of heaven and the beautiful light
of the eternal truth therefore the endowment of the human reason is left drunk with the things
of the earth now what i'm going to read now is a perfect description of our society today
okay therefore the endowment of the human reason because our society worshiped the reason
is left drunk with the things of the earth and so she does not have a firm step she staggers to
the right and to the left wrapping herself more in the tick darkness that surrounds her and the
world today is literally embedded in tick darkness therefore there's no greater misfortune than the
soul who let yourself be dominated by her own will now that's as clear as daylight
so the complete opposite works for the person who is dominated by the divine will
my will makes the soul grow straight now that's the biblical image of the palm tree
and i want to give you sam 92 verses 12 to 15 you grow tall and strong like the pantry
so the pantry grows up towards heaven it's not bending down towards the earth
she grows straight in such a way that she cannot bend towards the earth you see why i'm giving you
the image of the pantry but she always looks at heaven her constant looking towards heaven forms
many exhalations of light which envelop her completely this cloud of light is so thick
that eclipsing all the things of the earth it makes them all disappear and in exchange it makes
reappear for her everything that is of heaven now in the former case the darkness enveloped
the person and made them look to the earth for everything and they lost their connection with heaven
in this case the person is looking towards heaven all the time and the earth is put in its place
so it's an entirely different perspective so it can be said that heaven is what this soul knows
and that all that belongs to heaven is what she loves my will renders her step firm and therefore
there's no danger that she will stagger even slightly because you are strengthened by the divine will
and the beautiful endowment of a healthy reason now notice the last person was operating reason
but it wasn't a healthy one because the people today who worship the reason are living completely
unreasonable lives so a healthy reason is so illumined by the light that envelops her as to move from
one truth to the other so she can move quite easily in the divine this light which of course is
comes to her as infused knowledge uncovers for her divine mysteries ineffable things and celestial
joys now don't forget that when you are looking and reading and trying to take on board the teachings
that are in these writings to ask the lord for this infused knowledge to ask him for this enlightenment
and to ask him to lift your eyes heavenward therefore the greatest fortune for a soul is to let herself
be dominated by my will he said she holds supremacy in everything she occupies the first place of
honour in the whole of creation that's Romans 8 19 she never moves away from the point at which
god delivered her god finds her always on his paternal knees there's the most wonderful image
of at the relationship we have with god in the divine will we're always on the paternal knees
which i think is brilliant and if you remember that it'll make interceding for others an awful
lot easier god finds her always on his paternal needs singing to him his glory his love and his
eternal will so since she is on the knees of the eternal father the first love is for her
the seas of graces which overflow continuously from the divine womb are hers the first kisses
the most loving caresses are all for her only to her can we entrust our secrets because
being the one who is closest to us and who remains more with us we let her share in all of our
things now there's a very quick summary of whole volumes that we have just been reading okay as i
was thinking about us being on the paternal knees the thing i remember is a statement of st rays of
lisue she was asked by her community once what's she afraid of judgment and she said of course i'm
not afraid of judgment i'll be sitting on his knee when he's judging the earth it was an absolutely
brilliant response to give so they sitting on the paternal knees is the position of highest intimacy
with god and therefore of course the hugs and the graces and the blessings and everything go to you
before they go to anybody else so the enormity of the privilege that we have cannot be exaggerated
and notice that the lord says that this soul remains more with him than anybody else so we
let her share all our things we form her life her joy and happiness and she forms our joy and our
happiness it's mutual because love is mutual and the effects of love are mutual okay in fact
since her will is won with ours and since our will possesses our very happiness it's no wonder
that by possessing our will the soul can give joys and happiness to us and so we make each other
happy okay so giving joy and happiness to god look at proverbs 8 31 so in the next paragraph then
we have the wonder of living in the divine will then my poor mind continued to think about the
difference that exists between one who let yourself be dominated by the supreme will and one who
let yourself be dominated by the human will and my greatest and only good at it my daughter my will
contains the creative power you've heard of say that hundreds of times now therefore it creates
in the soul the strength the grace the light and the very beauty which the divine will once
its own things to be done by the soul in other words the lord creates in us what he wants to find
there he's not going to get it any other way so i want to give you sam 51 verses 10 to 12 create
in me clean heart oh god and don't forget that we can ask the lord to create in us whatever we perceive
is not available or whatever is missing and he loves creating he just likes an invitation it's
really good so number one the soul feels a divine strength within herself as if it were her own
number two the soul feels a grace which is sufficient for the good that she must do
or for a pain that she must suffer number three the soul feels a light or infused knowledge
which as though naturally makes her see the good that she does and attracted by the beauty of the
divine work that she performs she rejoices and she makes feasts because the works that my will
performs in the soul carry the mark of joy some of you are doing revelation with me and you know
that there was the mark of cane in the book of genesis and there's the mark of god's children
in the book of revelation and there's the mark of the beast for those who are giving themselves
to damnation okay so the soul carries the mark of joy and perennial feast now here's a little key
because throughout these writings you are given little keys all the time in which you can test
that you are actually in the divine will and that is you notice that people living in the divine
will are actually very joyful people they may be suffering but they're still full of joy
okay that's one of the marks of a person living in the divine will this feast was started
by my fiat in creation but it was interrupted by the split of the human will from that of god
and as the soul lets the supreme will operate and dominate the feast resumes its course
and the amusement the games and the delights continue between the creature and us that sam
36 verse 8 the delights in god there's no unhappiness or sorrow within us how could we give it to anybody
else and so if these souls feel unhappiness it's because they leave the divine will and
implose themselves in the little field of the human will there's a slipping back
therefore as they return to this divine will they will find the joys the happiness the power
strength light and the beauty of their creator so everything is positive and glorious in moving
towards it everything is terrible in moving away from it and so we can use that as a discernment
for ourselves therefore it's always a feast between us and the soul so whether she has joy
or even sorrow in life she will still be fine so the next paragraph we're back to the disaster
of living in the human will on the other hand it's very jewish to say on the one hand and on the
other hand that's the way they speak and i just noticed this very jewish thing in these writings
and i actually love it on the other hand in the human will there's not a creative power
which if one wants to exercise the virtues might be able to create patience how often you would
have liked to create patience wouldn't you it can't create humility or obedience or anything like that
and this is why one feels hardship and fatigue in order to be able to practice the virtues
because the divine strength that sustains them the creative power that nourishes them and gives
them life is missing and so what you have in constancy and one passes easily from virtues to
vices from prayer to dissipation from church to amusements oh my goodness have you ever noticed
that on sundays from patience to impatience all this mix of good and evil produces unhappiness in
the creature and that's where people are at who are only living at the level of virtues they can go
very easily from one to the other without even realizing it on the other hand one who lets my
will reign within herself she feels firmness in good she actually feels that constancy within her
she feels that all things brings her happiness and joy more so since all the things created by us
carry the mark here we're at the mark again the seed of joy and happiness so there's the mark he's
telling us of someone who lives truly lives in the divine will there is joy and happiness in that
soul even if they're sick or suffering or bereaved or anything else so they carry the joy and the
happiness of the one who created them and they were created by us so that all of them might bring
happiness to man each created thing has a mandate from us to bring to the creature the happiness
and the joy it possesses so there is the joy you get from looking a beautifully ripe apple of a
tree or pulling up some wonderful vegetation from the ground the joy that it actually gives to you
and the Lord is saying to us that joy and happiness was put into that thing for you
in fact what joy and happiness doesn't the light of the sun not bring what pleasure do the blue
heavens the flowery field a murmuring sea not bring to one's sight we get such joy at looking at the
beauty of nature what enjoyment do a sweet and tasty fruit some very fresh water and many many
other things not bring to you all created things say to man in their own mute language we bring you
the happiness and the joy of our creator but the sad thing is that somebody living on the lower level
won't even notice they will take the fruit and they'll take the vegetable and they'll
enjoy the meat of the animals and so on without any gratitude to god so do you know in whom all
created things find the echo of their joy and happiness of course it's in the one they will find
my will raining and dominating so there is a reciprocal thing going on between all the creatures
that god has made and it's no harm to imitate St Francis in actually thanking the plants primitive
peoples always remembered to thank an animal that they killed in order to give them life and to thank
the plants for actually giving them the health that they actually needed sometimes our grace before
meals is a bit starchy and it's not it's not in relation to the plants and the animals who've given
their lives for us but to thank them for their sacrifice to give us life would actually remind
us of our rounds much better so in one in whom they find my will raining and dominating because
that will which reigns in them as a whole that which god himself possesses and that which reigns in the
soul become one this is the same divine will in god and in us becomes one and it makes seas of joy
and happiness and contentment overflow into one another so in this final paragraph effort tonight
the lord wants to say to us that for us to live in the divine will it's not only the greatest thing
for us it's the greatest thing for god as well he has managed to get his creature up onto the level
that he wanted all the time therefore my daughter every time you fuse yourself in my will and please
do it hundreds of times a day if you can and you go around through all created things to impress your
love your glory or adoration upon each thing i created to make you happy i feel joy and happiness
and glory being renewed in me as in the act in which we issued the creation so the joy he had in
creating is actually renewed when he gets this response from us you cannot understand the feast
that you make for us when we see your littlest which wanting to embrace everything in our will
repays us in love and in glory for all created things our joy is so great that we put everything
aside to enjoy the joy and the feast that you give to us therefore this is the important bit
this is the biggest thing tonight therefore to live in the supreme will is the greatest thing for us
and for the soul it is the outpouring of the creator over the creature and outpouring himself
over her he gives her his own shape makes her like god and makes her share all the divine qualities
in such a way that we feel our works our joy our happiness being repeated in her and we have reached
our goal the lord has managed to divinize us with all his labor all his sacrifice all his grace
all his patience and all his encouragement that he gives to us so we leave it there for tonight
and thank you for joining us.